hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
fallout from the contentious first
presidential debate
continues former george w bush
speechwriter mark thiessen
and democratic strategist for the fox
news channel juan williams weigh in
on the fiery face-off in cleveland and
what they think both candidates need to
work on
in the run-up to election day saturday
will mark
25 years since o.j simpson was acquitted
of two counts of murder in the killings
of his ex-wife nicole brown simpson
and her friend ron goldman retired los
angeles police department detective
mark furman a key witness in the highly
publicized trial
discusses the controversial verdict its
impact
and his fox nation show the furman
diaries which investigates some of the
nation's most memorable cases
and mysteries plus commentary by fox
nation host
tammy bruce the fox news rundown is a
daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm maria bartiromo i'm greg gutfeld i'm
liz clayman
and this is the fox news rundown
friday october 2nd 2020 i'm lisa brady
president trump says he easily won the
first debate
but was there any winner in that chaotic
contest
president needs to mute himself a little
bit more going forward and you know stop
interrupting biden let him
let him dig a hole for himself i'm chris
foster
it's 25 years tomorrow that o.j simpson
was found not guilty of murdering nicole
brown simpson and ron goldman
former lapd detective mark furman says
it's still hard to live with
physical evidence that is observed not
dna
just physical evidence and everything
that fits together
so well a jury could do such
an incredibly poor job and i'm tammy
bruce
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
the dust is still settling from that
first showdown between president trump
and former vice president joe biden you
are ignoring the problem here which is
last week
in pennsylvania you had ballots found in
a ditch white house spokeswoman kaylee
mcinerney getting pushback from
reporters during a thursday briefing
about the president's continued attacks
on mail-in voting
and his position on white supremacists
the president has pronounced
white supremacy the kkk and hate groups
in all forms
even though the democratic nominee has
been accused of failing to answer
certain questions
the president's proud boys moment has
gotten the most attention
i'm willing to do anything i want to see
people do it sir say it
do it say it do you want to call him
what do you want to call him give me
your name give me a white surprise
stand back and stand by the next day
when asked again
his message was stand down but he also
said he didn't even know
who the proud boys are the perception of
the american people was
fairly or not that he didn't condem
white supremacy and i think that is
damaging
mark thiessen is a former speechwriter
for president george w
bush american enterprise institute
fellow and fox news contributor
here's the problem there are so here's
here i'll give you a perfect example
there's a new york times sienna poll
that just came out right before the
before the debate 46 of americans
approve of the job the president's doing
54 percent approve his handling of the
economy
but only 41 say they plan to vote for
him so there's a lot of voters who think
trump's doing a pretty good job
they like his economic performance but
they're not planning to give him a
second term
why is that uh one of the reasons is is
because i think some of them are
exhausted by what we saw on the debate
stage on tuesday and the constant
controversies and all the rest of it
the other thing is they keep getting
told that donald trump's a racist um
and you know fairly or not that
impression is you know no one wants to
vote for someone who they're told as a
racist
assuming that some voters might be
making judgments
on the candidates based on the debates
do you think it's a mistake for the
president to push back too hard
on any possible changes the debate
commission might make
well it depends on what they are i mean
they're talking about you know
having a mute button or something like
that which is ridiculous and i remember
it reminds me of uh
in 1980 during the republican primary
ronald reagan was uh
was debating and the moderator said cut
off his microphone and he yelled i'm
paying for this microphone
it was one of the most famous uh moments
of his campaign now trump isn't paying
for the microphone
he's president of the united states he
don't mute the president um
but you know trump probably president
needs to mute himself a little bit more
going forward and you know stop
interrupting biden let him
let him dig a hole for himself uh let
him not answer questions like
are you going to pack the supreme court
are you going to add two states
and add four democratic senators to pack
the senate are you going to expand the
house of representatives and
pack the electoral college um let him
start
asking let him get stuck with tough
questions and
if he's not answering it then turn the
american people and say he won't answer
he won't tell you
you may not like me but what he's
offering is worse
um that's the message he needs to get
across those persuadable voters
the turnout for early voting has been
really big in some areas
and in areas where it's considered to
maybe be a democrat advantage
should republicans be worried about that
i think the democrats
achilles heel is that they have invested
way more heavily in mail-in voting
and look i don't agree with the
president there's widespread fraud
in mail-in voting but even if there's
not fraud
mail in votes have a very high failure
rate there was an mit study of the
2008 election and which mail where
mail-in voting was
much less prevalent than it's going to
be now and there was a failure rate of
almost 21
where people and it's and they the the
ballots are discounted not because of
fraud
because the person filled it out
incorrectly they didn't they didn't get
the affidavit sign
their signature didn't match they didn't
they didn't post market in time
there's all sorts of reasons why where
people make mistakes if you walk into a
voting
center and you're having trouble filling
out your ballot you can ask somebody how
do i fill this out what do i do and they
can fix it for you
but if you do it in mail and you send it
in wrong it doesn't get counted
and so democrats are exponentially more
likely
to vote by mail which means their votes
are exponentially more likely to not get
counted
the president has had the edge in the
polls on the economy
so how vulnerable is he if there are
certain
things heading backwards leading up to
the election
like the 28 000 theme park layoffs
that disney just announced yeah but the
overall the economy is doing better i
mean we've gained
over like we've gained something like 11
million uh 11 million jobs in the last
uh
in the last three months uh so we i
think we've probably
recovered about half almost half of the
jobs that were lost during the
during the shutdown and joe biden's the
candidate who's saying we might have to
shut down again
no one wants to shut down again so the
economy is going to be
going to be improving dramatically going
into the going into uh
going into election day i mean it's
still it's still going to take a while
for us to recover fully from the
pandemic but
the economy is going to be on the
upswing and the president is going to be
able to say to the american people
uh do you want to keep this going in the
right direction you want to or you want
to
trust joe biden to with with the future
of your of your job
i think that issue cuts very much in the
president's favor
joe biden got through tuesday's debate
without any major gaffes and without
really losing his temper
but it's hard to get any word in with
this clown he did
have those name-calling moments i'm not
going to answer the question
because you answered that because the
question is the question is
justice left would you shut up
so could that damage one of his core
messages
of restoring leadership and decency to
the white house
i think it was not a good moment for joe
biden so many ways
juan williams is a democratic political
analyst co-host of the five and fox news
contributor
you know it was like you know what did
they say that analogy getting in the mud
with
you know a farm animal you get dirty and
they get pleasure from it
but on the other hand i do think this
that historically now
there's a thirst on the part of
democrats for somebody who can take
on donald trump somebody who's not going
to back down or let him
as hillary clinton did walk up behind
them call them nasty woman that's
somebody who will respond in kind
and so for a certain group of people and
i think lots of younger democrats in
particular
it was quite satisfying but i think that
overall
if you're just looking at the overall
audience i think people
just thought that debate was a debacle
and wish that
no one had had to resort to those kinds
of tactics
what about the questions that he's biden
is not answering and i'm thinking in
particular of the you know whether or
not he would agree to packing the
supreme court
do you think that voters care about that
not much it's critical for the trump
campaign because what they
they're trying to do is establish in the
voter's mind that
biden's not being forthcoming or that
biden is someone who is going to change
the rules
and what you have here is a situation
where the biden campaign
and the democrats are making the
argument that we don't know
how things play out clearly they're
dissatisfied with the idea that
president trump is rushing
a nominee through the confirmation
process most americans agree that it is
a rush
and think that the next president should
be the one to select the nominee
for the open court seat but here is the
thing
if in fact you do get another trump
nominee confirmed you will have a six to
three court
and the big argument here as presented
by the biden campaign is over
the substance the real issues that would
be impacted including the affordable
care act as you know
but also possibly the outcome of the
election if
there are questions about balloting and
voter fraud
and they end up in the supreme court
there have been
long lines for early voting in some
places and the thinking is democrats
might have an advantage there
but how important is it then not to
become
overconfident oh gosh so important
and i think that's why you see all the
emphasis coming from
the get out the vote campaign of lots of
people
um and i think you're going to see
bernie sanders
uh to barack obama on the campaign trail
shortly and the emphasis
will be on get out and vote do
everything you can make plans almost
like it's an emergency you know you have
an emergency
food supply or exit plan in case of an
attack on the country or something
they're making they're putting it to
that level lisa that you have to have a
plan for how you're going to vote and
vote early if possible
the president keeps questioning the
integrity of the election
whether there you know might not be a
peaceful transfer of power depending on
how it goes
democrats though have talked about
things like lawsuits
potential unrest uh even a
second civil war in the case of at least
one you know commentator
are both sides guilty of inflammatory
language and really trying to scare the
voters
i think that's part of american politics
in every campaign i mean obviously i
wasn't around
for the early 1800s but uh you know
going back and reading about it and you
can see that both sides not only would
engage in inflammatory language
but they would engage in personal
attacks defamation they'd use the press
to their advantage so
it's all part of the democratic process
i mean the big difference of course in
modern times is social media
and the intensity of it and even people
like
bots and russian interference and
propaganda
misleading people you know videos that
are manipulated
that's the big change in our era but the
use of inflammatory charges
or scare tactics pure american democracy
i know there's been a little bit of a
shift um or maybe they were planning to
do it at the end
all along but it seems like a little
shift in the biden campaign strategy of
late where he is getting out
and um you know leaving delaware
leaving his home and going out and doing
more events still kind of low key events
but i also saw that some campaign
operators are now starting to do
voter canvassing again after stepping
away from that not wanting to
go up to people's doors during the
pandemic is that a signal
that they feel like they need to step on
the gas a bit
or you know does it result from concern
among democrats that maybe they weren't
seen as doing enough as the president is
holding these rallies
what do you make of that does he need to
change anything in these final few weeks
you know i think that there's a fear
going back to the 2016
campaign when hillary clinton didn't go
to wisconsin
that unless they push all the buttons
they may have regrets so in this
situation
there was a decision made by the biden
campaign specifically by
uh jennifer dylan o'malley the campaign
manager
that americans during the pandemic
really don't want people
coming up to their door strangers and
knocking
and maybe even trying to come in in
order to
appeal to their political taste they
just didn't
think that was a smart move i think you
now see
one the biden campaign saying at least
in those swing states and i'm thinking
in the upper midwest wisconsin
michigan stretching across maybe even to
minnesota but also
including pennsylvania on the east that
they are going to start
doing some door knocking with the idea
being
show the you know the passion show the
flag maybe even put more money into
signage
uh because they haven't in the past but
i think now as we enter
the final few you know today is october
2nd um you see them really making sure
that they have
pushed all the buttons so that they'll
be no regrets come november 3rd
democratic political analyst juan
williams thank you so much for your time
lisa what a pleasure always good to talk
with you
[Music]
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
october 3rd 1995 o.j simpson and the
world
heard this at his trial in los angeles
we the jury in the above
and title action find the defendant or
john orenthal james simpson not guilty
of the crime of murder
in violation of penal code section 187 a
a felony upon nicole brown simpson a
human being as charged in count one of
the information
he was also acquitted of murdering his
ex-wife's friend ron goldman
most people old enough to have followed
the case at the time remembers watching
or hearing about the verdict
well i was in idaho ready to go on an
elk hunt
and i remember coming back into the
house and my wife said
they're going to blame this all on you
one of the witnesses in the trial was
lapd detective mark furman now a fox
news contributor
he found a bloody glove at the murder
scene simpson's defense team claimed he
planted it there and to undermine his
credibility
played tapes of detective furman in a
side job as a consultant to a
screenwriter
using racial slurs talking about black
people he eventually pleaded no contest
to perjury and got probation for
testifying that he had not used racial
slurs in the last 10 years
he says the evidence in the simpson case
was overwhelming it's always
shocking and it will remain shocking for
all time
that the case that has had the most
documented scientific evidence
testimonial evidence
physical evidence that is observed not
dna
just physical evidence and everything
that fits together
so well a jury could do such
an incredibly poor job and then
maybe this is uh maybe self-serving
but to use race where race wasn't an
issue
is always fascinating to me because then
you know that
there is guilt um everywhere in the case
and so i watch now where we were doing
that same thing where because
somebody's race is
a certain race they become right
regardless
of the evidence and most of the time
they're actually the people that
actually stimulate the
the contact by law enforcement whether
it be a homicide or
a shooting or a riot or anything else so
you know i don't think you ever get over
it i mean regardless of the color of
orinthal james simpson's skin he
certainly ran in for the most part
wealthy white circles before all this
happened he was
playing plenty friends with with cops
from what i understand
yeah i mean he had he had a couple
friends that were cops and
and i knew uh i knew one of them and he
was
he was somebody i i had worked with and
uh
you know he wasn't
i mean nobody looked at him in that way
in retrospect you hear of everybody it's
like
it was just oj it wasn't o.j the black
running back it was oj and so
you know he associated with anybody and
everybody but
you know he he certainly didn't align
himself that he was black he was o.j
simpson he was a football player so you
know it's it's
it's always something that we will talk
about
because we don't understand it and
that's the reason we keep talking about
in an attempt to understand the process
of thought when it comes down to the
murder of two innocent people
nicole was beaten up a lot over the
years
by oj and we didn't talk about domestic
violence as much
then uh it seemed that it was
you know it certainly wasn't legal but
it's something that happened between
husbands and wives i wonder how
that would play out differently now at
trial
well it would have played out
differently then at trial had marcia
clark pursued this
in the stark uh evidence
that was presented this wasn't a
domestic violence situation
this was someone that was spying on an
ex-wife and got
caught and got involved in an
altercation with her
and then ron goldman walked up that
walkway and simpson attacked him once he
did that
and killed him he had to kill nicole so
this was
you know not a first degree murder
this was on ron goldman's part
this was a rage based murder and then
once he killed ron the first degree
murder was going back to the unconscious
nicole and killing her which now became
a premeditated murder but he didn't go
there to kill two people
this wasn't a domestic situation this
was
his ego about possessing things and he
believed he possessed nicole i'm sure
he spied on her a lot that was one of
the things and this time he got
caught and when he got caught
things started tumbling over themselves
and
one thing led to another and we ended up
with a double homicide
this was not as clear-cut as marcia
clark
wanted it to be but she wanted it to be
domestic
violence because she had been a victim
of domestic
domestic violence at least that's what i
have been told
um how do you feel now or do you try to
try to avoid it i mean simpson
did his time in prison for the other
stuff in las vegas for the robbery
and now he's out on twitter playing golf
being
being kind of flip about everything i
mean do you suppose that that's his
right
i mean i guess
it's i mean he served his time
yeah legally legally has the right but
morally
it would be it would be nice if he just
shut up he beat the system once
and he was so arrogant the system caught
him for a lesser
crime but still they put him in prison
that time and still
still he's running in his mouth instead
of just realizing just how incredibly
lucky he is in the long run
this shows you the kind of personality
he has it's all about oj
and he's such a narcissist that
you know he has to have some level of
recognition and limelight
he has to be in front of a camera or in
front of a microphone even if he does it
himself and
you know it's it's really telling the
kind of person
and how obsessive he is about certain
things he just doesn't know when
to stop and this these are the kind of
person
people that end up killing their exes or
their current wives or
girlfriends and time and time again we
see this and
yet people really don't see the forest
for the trees with these people
they are who they are and they're never
going to change
mark furman hosts the series streaming
on fox nation the furman diaries where
he looks into the evidence in famous
criminal cases
season five is out now with cases
including the serial killer samuel
little
the shoe bomber richard reed the atlanta
child murders
and the actress natalie woods death if
you had no power and no money
would they just explain away a broken
wine bottle on the floor when somebody
died of an accidental drowning would
they allow an attorney to get between
you
and interviewing a person that might
know something about a death
no episode one is about the west memphis
three
it is so so terribly
uh an injustice to these three young men
there is absolutely zero evidence
that connects them to the homicide of
three
eight-year-old boys who were hog tied
and thrown in a drainage creek
in west memphis
you know in 19 in 1993.
so when i look at this i keep looking
for
the evidence that a detective could
assume
or go down a path that at that time
might have led him to believe but there
is nothing
and this you know this part of the bible
belt
when the detective said this is
a crime of a satanic cult
then that became written in stone
and now these three kids two of which
liked heavy metal music and dressed in
black and didn't have the same haircuts
as everybody else
obviously were the suspects and that's
how
they were identified and then from there
it went to the confession of one of them
that was a borderline
uh [ __ ] young man with an iq of 72
and you know not like like you said not
to give it all away but there's a
12-hour interrogation
of which the detectives fed this young
man everything that they could
to have him give them a recorded
45-minute conversation
that implicated the two other boys in
the homicide yet
none of that none of those statements
fit the evidence at the scene so the
detective simply
ignored the evidence at the scene and
it's just it goes on and on uh i was
in complete shock that in 1993
we could actually do this it makes the
o.j simpson case
look like a breath of fresh air
do we know who killed those kids
i would suspect that it is one of two
people or two people
there's there's evidence that i actually
conclude that there could have been
actually two suspects or one of the
victims
assisting uh the suspect
in in tying up the uh
the eight-year-old boys uh but there is
dna
in one of the knots of one of the
ligatures
on one of the victims that belongs
to the father one of the victims
so that dna came out a long time later
there was bite marks on two of the
victims that the detectives just
we're not even going to worry about this
they're even described
in the autopsy we're not going to worry
about this we're not going to get bite
impressions of the possible suspects
we're not the other guys eliminate or
include them
but the fathers both the fathers
one had a partial denture one had all of
his natural teeth
one father had all of his teeth pulled
out in 1997
and the other father the partial denture
that he has goes missing
so you you kind of wonder why the
detectives aren't pursuing
some of these obvious
obvious pieces of of the puzzle that
need to be filled in
answered and and they just stick with
this
and today even though these three boys
are out of prison the head detective
detective gitzel the one that said
that it was a satanic cult that killed
these three boys
he says those are the suspects all right
well if you like true
true crime documentaries go check out
the latest season of the furman diaries
they're streaming on fox nation
uh mark it's good to talk to you thanks
for coming on the fox news rundown well
thank you
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at
and foxnewspodcasts.com some good news
with tanya j powers
[Music]
distance learning has become a way of
life for many students across the
country during the pandemic
like other parents mitchell couch of
lamore california says he wanted his
dining room table to be more for eating
and less for schooling
mitchell likes to build things in his
free time and he's been a carpenter for
about 20 years
so he decided to make his kids their own
school desks
he posted a video showing how he did it
in case anybody else wanted the
information
and posted it to youtube he says he had
200 messages the day after he posted it
and he got such a good response that he
made another one
hey everybody so i got a lot of traction
on the last video i did that had to do
with building your own
diy folding desk during these times we
have a lot of kids that are still at
home they're not able to go to school
writing all this homework around and you
gotta move it and take it down
it's just a diy desk that anybody can
build in it he walks his fellow builders
through what they'll need
showing them all the steps okay so now
we got our two
top and bottom pieces cut out 24 inches
by eight it's been viewed more than 14
000 times
and he's got more than 3 000 subscribers
now
four inches wide he's also gotten a big
following on tick tock and instagram
okay this is it built it it is so sturdy
i built this for twenty dollars
basically you can build four desks out
of one full sheet
of four foot by eight foot piece of
plywood like to do is just get this
spread around
let everybody know about it mitchell has
been working to build desks for others
in his community
with his whole family joining in to help
your kid
or kids are going to love it it's their
own little personal workspace
you can stain it paint it decorate it
put stickers on it
distant learning is difficult at this
time i understand it's got its
challenges i promise you all the
teachers are doing
everything they can to help your student
out so
this will get the kids off the kitchen
table you can put this in their room
maybe give them some quiet time make it
wider if you want that's up to you
again i made this for less than twenty
dollars so good luck
you can find mitchell on youtube at ml
couch
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
it's tammy bruce
what's on your mind right on cue liberal
women's groups came out swinging against
judge amy coney barrett president
trump's nominee for justice of the u.s
supreme court
the fear and anger porn of the left is
expected of course
we saw what the democrats were capable
of with justice kavanaugh
so it's not surprising they're
attempting to smear judge barrett with
falsehoods
equally obscene the real story here
is judge barrett is not just fit for the
supreme court
she is actually the perfect
representative for the legacy of the
late justice ruth bader ginsburg
when justice ginsburg began her career
she had to carve her own path
and face down those who condemned her
because she dared to want something
different
than what the status quo demanded of her
she worked and fought to be able to make
choices in life
that best suited her fast forward to the
21st century
and the nomination of judge barrett who
is ironically in a very similar position
she faces judgment smears resistance and
condemnation
by warped american liberals and the
typically intolerant left
for daring to not conform she has
committed the crime of having chosen a
life and philosophy
not understood by nor sanctioned by
the american democratic machine make no
mistake judge barrett is exactly who
justice ginsburg
and every other genuine feminist should
recognize as a symbol of our success
if you were actually hoping women would
be free to be themselves
justice ginsburg's work help to make it
easier of course for women to pursue
their dreams
especially when society tells them
otherwise yet judge barrett is facing
judgment from the liberal chattering
class
for being a working mother with
questions from the left about her
ability to be a professional woman
and still be able to properly care for
her children
perhaps they should just be yelling at
her to stay in the kitchen
legacy media brings up her catholicism
as though it is a dangerous thing
as is her relationship with god and its
influence on her life
in addition to trying to indict judge
barrett because of her faith
her family one influencer calls into
question
her intentions by adopting two children
from haiti
declaring it a version of get this white
colonialism
that of course is obscene and an affront
to everyone who is adopted
seeing and loving children for who not
what
they are justice ginsburg would
recognize this grotesque attempt
to destroy a woman because she dares to
be her own person
all of us have watched the growing
intolerance among the left now
manifesting
as religious bigotry and misogyny
ultimately judge barrett is the most
obvious person to ascend to the supreme
court in the wake of justice ginsburg
this 48 year old mother of seven thrust
international scrutiny
is a woman we all recognize you may not
agree with her judicial philosophy
you may have made very different choices
than she has in life
and your family may look very different
but she is
all of us in that she made choices that
best suited her
she now faces an american machine
determined to destroy her bizarrely
in the name of defending ruth bader
ginsburg
and women everywhere the real reminder
in all of this
is that we're all amy coney barrett we
all want to live lives that best suit us
we all want to have a chance to pursue
our dreams we would all love to reach
the pinnacle of our professions
but we at least want to be able to try
without fear
of destruction this is tammy bruce
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
it's the perino and stir walt i'll tell
you what podcast
dana parino of the five and fox news
political editor chris steierwell
dissect the ins and outs of national
politics
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes